selamat datang kembali di Understanding Quantum Information and Computation nama saya John Watus dan saya adalah direktur teknis bidang pendidikan di IBM
Quantum ini adalah pelajaran nomor 15 dari seri ini dan merupakan pelajaran ketiga dari unit keempat yang membahas tentang koreksi error
kuantum sejauh ini kita telah melihat beberapa contoh kode koreksi error kuantum termasuk kode Shore sembilan Cubit
kode Steane 7 Cubit dan kode 5 Cubit dan kita juga telah membahas formalisme stabilizer yang memberikan
fondasi matematis dari mana kita bisa mendeskripsikan dan menganalisis kode-kode koreksi error kuantum ini dan banyak lainnya
kode-kode yang baru saya sebutkan tak diragukan lagi menarik dan mewakili tempat alami untuk memulai
eksplorasi koreksi error kuantum masalahnya adalah bahwa mereka hanya bisa mentoleransi tingkat error yang sangat rendah
mengoreksi error pada satu qubit dari lima tujuh atau sembilan tidaklah buruk tapi kemungkinan besar setidaknya sejauh yang kita perkirakan
kita akan perlu bisa mentoleransi jauh lebih banyak error dari itu agar komputasi kuantum berskala besar menjadi
kenyataan dalam pelajaran ini kita akan pertama kali melihat beberapa konstruksi kode koreksi error kuantum yang lebih canggih termasuk kode yang bisa
mentoleransi tingkat error yang jauh lebih tinggi dari yang telah kita lihat sejauh ini dan dipandang sebagai kandidat yang menjanjikan untuk koreksi error kuantum praktis dalam
perangkat fisik nyata berikut adalah gambaran singkat dari pelajaran kita akan mulai dengan kelas
kode koreksi error kuantum yang dikenal sebagai kode CSS dinamai sesuai peneliti yang pertama kali menemukannya Robert Calderbank Peter
Shor dan Andrew Steane konstruksi kode CSS memungkinkan seseorang untuk mengambil pasangan tertentu dari kode
koreksi error klasik dan menggabungkannya menjadi kode koreksi error kuantum sebagai bagian dari diskusi tersebut kita akan
melihat secara singkat kode linear klasik dan kita juga akan membahas beberapa sifat dasar dari kode CSS
bagian kedua dari pelajaran ini membahas sebuah kode yang dikenal sebagai kode Torus yang merupakan contoh fundamental dan sangat
indah dari kode koreksi error kuantum yang bisa mentoleransi tingkat error yang relatif tinggi bahkan
kode Torus bukanlah contoh tunggal dari kode koreksi error kuantum melainkan ia adalah keluarga kode yang tak terbatas satu untuk
setiap bilangan bulat positif mulai dari dua dan di bagian terakhir pelajaran kita akan secara singkat membahas beberapa keluarga kode kuantum lainnya termasuk surface code yang terkait erat dengan kode Torus serta
kode warna orang-orang telah mempelajari kode koreksi error klasik sejak tahun 1940-an
dan ini adalah subjek yang menarik dan kaya kode linear mungkin adalah jenis koreksi error klasik yang paling sederhana
dan saya akan menjelaskan persis apa yang dimaksud kata linear dalam konteks ini sebentar lagi tapi satu cara sederhana
untuk mengekspresikan apa mereka adalah bahwa mereka adalah kode stabilizer yang kebetulan klasik dan kita akan segera melihat bahwa
kode CSS pada dasarnya adalah pasangan kode linear klasik yang digabungkan bersama untuk membuat kode koreksi error
kuantum jadi demi diskusi tersebut kita perlu memahami beberapa hal dasar tentang
kode linear klasik terlebih dahulu kita akan mengambil Sigma sebagai alfabet biner untuk seluruh
diskusi ini dan sekarang ketika kita menyebut kode linear klasik kita maksudkan himpunan C dari string biner dengan panjang n untuk beberapa
bilangan bulat positif n yang memenuhi hanya satu properti dasar yaitu jika u dan v adalah string biner dalam C maka string
u XOR v juga ada dalam C di sini omong-omong u XOR v berarti exclusive or bitwise dari u dan v seperti
yang kita lihat beberapa kali di pelajaran lima dan enam dalam bagian algoritma kuantum dari seri ini dan inilah yang dimaksud dengan sebuah
kode klasik yang linear pada dasarnya kita memikirkan string biner dengan panjang n sebagai vektor n-dimensi
di mana entri semuanya adalah nol atau satu tapi alih-alih penjumlahan vektor biasa atas bilangan real atau kompleks
kita menggunakan penjumlahan modulo 2 yang hanyalah XOR jadi jika kita punya
dua code word u dan v yang berarti u dan v adalah string biner dalam C maka U plus v modulo 2 atau dengan kata lain u XOR
V harus juga merupakan code word dalam C dan omong-omong implikasi ini harus benar bahkan jika U sama dengan V tidak ada yang mengecualikan
kemungkinan itu dan itu mengimplikasikan bahwa setiap kode linear klasik harus mengandung string all-zero karena
XOR bitwise dari sebarang string dengan dirinya sendiri adalah string all-zero misalnya kode
repetisi tiga bit adalah kode linear klasik khususnya ada dua pilihan yang mungkin untuk U dan dua pilihan yang mungkin
untuk V dan sangat mudah untuk memeriksa semua pasangan yang mungkin untuk melihat bahwa kita selalu mendapatkan code word saat kita mengambil XOR bitwise
berikut adalah contoh lain yang disebut kode Hamming 7-4-3 ini adalah salah satu kode koreksi error klasik pertama
yang pernah ditemukan dan terdiri dari 16 string biner dengan panjang tujuh ada logika yang sangat sederhana
di balik pemilihan string-string ini tapi saya tidak akan menjelaskannya dalam video ini dan saya juga harus menyebutkan bahwa kamu terkadang akan melihat string-string ini dibalik tapi
untuk sekarang poin utamanya adalah bahwa jika kita mengambil dua string mana pun dan mengXOR keduanya kita akan mendapatkan string lain dalam
kode jadi ini adalah kode linear dan notasi 7-4-3 dalam satu tanda kurung siku berarti sesuatu yang analog dengan notasi kurung siku ganda
yang saya sebutkan dalam pelajaran sebelumnya untuk kode stabilizer tapi di sini ini untuk kode linear
klasik khususnya code word memiliki tujuh bit ada 16 code word sehingga kita bisa mengkodekan empat bit menggunakan kode ini dan
kebetulan ini adalah kode dengan jarak tiga yang berarti kamu harus membalik setidaknya tiga bit dari code word mana pun untuk mendapatkan
code word yang berbeda dan itu mengimplikasikan bahwa ia bisa mengoreksi hingga satu error bit flip ini adalah contoh sederhana dari
kode tapi bahkan contoh kode Hamming 7-4-3 terlihat agak misterius ketika kita hanya mendaftar semua code word jadi kita memerlukan cara yang lebih baik untuk
mendeskripsikan kode linear klasik dan ada dua cara alami untuk melakukannya satu cara adalah dengan mendeskripsikan kode linear
klasik dengan memberikan himpunan minimal dari code word yang menghasilkan kode tersebut yang berarti bahwa dengan mengambil semua subset yang mungkin
dari code word-code word ini dan mengXOR keduanya kita mendapatkan seluruh kode dan itu diekspresikan dalam istilah matematis
di sini di layar cara lain untuk memikirkan ini adalah bahwa kita melihat kode ini sebagai subruang dari ruang vektor dan himpunan
generator ini adalah basis untuk subruang tersebut mengingat bahwa ini adalah ruang vektor di mana aritmatika dilakukan modulo 2 jika kita punya M generator kita akan
mendapatkan kode yang memiliki dua pangkat m elemen setiap generator menggandakan jumlah elemen dalam kode dan
itu konsisten dengan fakta bahwa kode linear klasik atas alfabet biner selalu mengandung jumlah string yang merupakan pangkat dari
dua cara alami kedua untuk mendeskripsikan kode linear klasik adalah dengan parity check secara khusus ini adalah daftar minimal
dari string biner yang memiliki panjang yang sama dengan string dalam kode sedemikian sehingga string-string dalam kode adalah tepat yang hasil kali biner
dengan setiap satu dari string parity check ini adalah nol di mana hasil kali biner hanyalah hasil kali dalam biasa
modulo 2 dan lagi itu adalah sesuatu yang kita temui kembali dalam pelajaran lima dalam konteks algoritma
kuantum dan alasan mereka disebut string parity check adalah bahwa string U tertentu memiliki hasil kali biner sama dengan
nol dengan v jika dan hanya jika bit-bit dari U yang bersesuaian dengan yang satu dalam V memiliki paritas genap
ketika kita mendeskripsikan kode linear klasik dengan cara ini menggunakan daftar minimal string parity check setiap string parity
check membagi jumlah string dalam kode dengan dua jadi untuk satu kode yang dideskripsikan dalam dua cara yang berbeda ini kita selalu akan memiliki m ditambah r sama dengan
n satu hal penting yang perlu diperhatikan di sini adalah bahwa hasil kali biner bukanlah hasil kali dalam dalam arti formal dan
khususnya ketika dua string memiliki hasil kali biner sama dengan nol itu tidak berarti bahwa mereka ortogonal dengan cara biasa yang kita pikirkan tentang
ortogonalitas misalnya hasil kali biner dari string satu satu dengan dirinya sendiri adalah nol jadi mungkin saja bahwa
salah satu dari string parity check ini sendiri ada dalam kode jadi itu hanya sesuatu yang perlu diingat
misalnya seperti yang sudah kita ketahui kode repetisi 3-bit adalah kode linear sehingga bisa dideskripsikan dalam kedua cara ini
khususnya hanya ada satu pilihan untuk generator yang berfungsi dan itu adalah 111 dan kita bisa alternatifnya mendeskripsikan
kode dengan dua string parity check ini yang seharusnya terlihat familiar dari diskusi kita sebelumnya tentang
kode ini dan untuk kode Hamming 7-4-3 kita bisa menggunakan generator ini dan parity check ini
dan di sini omong-omong semua string parity check kita ternyata sendiri ada dalam kode
kode komentar terakhir tentang kode linear klasik hanya untuk menghubungkannya ke formalisme stabilizer string parity check ini
setara dengan generator stabilizer di mana kita hanya punya matriks Pauli Z dan identitas misalnya string parity check
110 dan 011 untuk kode repetisi 3-bit bersesuaian tepat dengan generator stabilizer ZZ identitas
dan identitas ZZ dan itu konsisten dengan diskusi kita tentang observabel jenis ini dari pelajaran sebelumnya
selanjutnya kita akan membahas kode CSS yang merupakan kode stabilizer yang bisa diperoleh dengan menggabungkan pasangan tertentu
dari kode linear klasik yang memiliki jumlah bit yang sama dalam pengkodeannya ini tidak berfungsi untuk sembarang dua
kode linear klasik kedua kode harus memiliki hubungan tertentu seperti yang akan kita lihat segera tapi meski begitu konstruksi
ini membuka banyak kemungkinan untuk kode koreksi error kuantum berdasarkan sebagian pada hal-hal yang telah kita pelajari dari lebih dari 75 tahun
teori koding klasik saya sudah menyebutkan bahwa dalam formalisme stabilizer generator stabilizer
yang mengandung hanya matriks Pauli Z dan identitas setara dengan parity check misalnya dalam kode repetisi tiga-bit
kita bisa menggunakan string parity check 1 1 0 dan 011 yang memastikan bahwa dua bit paling kiri adalah
sama dan dua bit paling kanan sama untuk setiap string dalam kode dan dua string parity check ini bersesuaian tepat dengan generator stabilizer
ZZ identitas dan identitas ZZ untuk kode Hamming 7-4-3 kita bisa menggunakan
string parity check ini dan mereka bersesuaian dengan generator stabilizer ini di mana kita hanya mengganti setiap satu dengan Z dan setiap nol dengan identitas
kamu mungkin mengenali generator stabilizer ini omong-omong karena ini adalah tiga dari enam generator stabilizer untuk kode Steane 7 Cubit itu
tentu bukan kebetulan dan kita akan melihat persis apa yang terjadi di sini segera kita akan memberi nama Z
stabilizer generator untuk generator stabilizer seperti ini yang berarti bahwa mereka hanya punya faktor tensor Pauli Z dan identitas
jadi X dan Y tidak pernah muncul dalam Z stabilizer generator kita juga bisa mempertimbangkan
generator stabilizer di mana hanya matriks Pauli X dan identitas yang muncul dan kita bisa memikirkan generator stabilizer seperti ini sebagai sepenuhnya analog
dengan Z stabilizer generator kecuali bahwa pada dasarnya mereka mendeskripsikan parity check dalam basis plus minus daripada
basis standar misalnya kembali ke kode Hamming 7-4-3 kita bisa memikirkan
tiga generator stabilizer yang tersisa dari kode Steane 7 Cubit yang kebetulan mengikuti pola yang persis sama seperti untuk Z stabilizer generator untuk
kode ini tapi kali ini kita mengganti X untuk satu daripada Z dan apa yang kita dapatkan hanya dari tiga generator stabilizer ini
adalah kode yang mencakup 16 keadaan yang ditampilkan di sini yang kita dapatkan dengan menerapkan Hadamard gate ke keadaan basis standar
yang bersesuaian dengan string-string dalam kode Hamming 7-4-3 dan tentu saja ruang kode kita juga mencakup
kombinasi linear dari keadaan-keadaan ini tentu saja generator stabilizer dalam bentuk ini disebut X stabilizer generator
jadi tidak ada y atau z yang diizinkan kali ini dan sekarang kita bisa mendefinisikan kode CSS dalam
istilah sederhana kode CSS adalah kode stabilizer yang bisa diekspresikan hanya menggunakan Z
stabilizer generator dan X stabilizer generator jadi tidak ada y yang diizinkan dan tidak ada x dan Z yang muncul dalam stabilizer generator yang sama
dan hanya untuk memastikan ini jelas kita perlu ingat bahwa ada kebebasan dalam cara kita memilih generator stabilizer untuk kode stabilizer
dan yang dikatakan definisi ini adalah bahwa kode CSS adalah kode yang memungkinkan untuk memilih hanya Z dan X
stabilizer generator tapi secara umum kamu bisa memilih generator stabilizer yang berbeda yang mungkin bukan Z atau X stabilizer generator jika kamu mau
berikut ini adalah contoh paling sederhana non-trivial dari kode CSS yang bisa kita miliki di mana ada Z stabilizer
generator dan X stabilizer generator dan memverifikasinya tidak memerlukan lebih dari sekilas pandang mengingat kita sudah tahu dari
pelajaran sebelumnya bahwa ini adalah kode stabilizer yang valid ruang kodenya adalah satu dimensi yaitu ruang yang dicakup oleh
fi Plus Bell dan kita bisa mengamati bahwa dua generator stabilizer kita bekerja secara trivial pada vektor ini dengan mempertimbangkan
dua ekspresi dari ebit yang ditampilkan di layar bersama dengan interpretasi generator stabilizer sebagai parity check dalam basis 0-1
dan plus-minus kode Steane 7 Cubit adalah contoh lain dari kode CSS karena untuk
pilihan generator ini kita hanya punya Z dan X stabilizer generator dan sekali lagi kita sudah tahu bahwa ini adalah
kode stabilizer yang valid dan kode Shore N9 Cubit adalah contoh lain kali ini kita punya enam Z
stabilizer generator dan hanya dua X stabilizer generator dan tidak masalah tidak perlu ada keseimbangan atau
simetri antara dua jenis tersebut namun yang kritis adalah bahwa kita benar-benar memiliki kode stabilizer yang valid dan itu berarti
bahwa setiap Z stabilizer generator harus komut dengan setiap X stabilizer generator jadi kamu tidak bisa
hanya memilih dua jenis generator secara independen dan saya akan sedikit lebih banyak membahas ini nanti dalam pelajaran selanjutnya kita akan membahas deteksi error
dan koreksi untuk kode CSS dan apa yang akan kita temukan adalah bahwa properti yang kita amati untuk kode Shore 9 Cubit
yaitu kita bisa mendeteksi dan mengoreksi X error dan Z error secara independen berlaku secara umum untuk kode CSS
untuk menjelaskan ini lebih lanjut mari kita pertimbangkan kode CSS seperti kode Steane 7 Cubit tapi bisa juga kode CSS yang berbeda jika
kamu mau ide dasarnya adalah bahwa Z stabilizer generator mendeteksi X error
tapi mereka sama sekali tidak menyadari Z error karena Z stabilizer generator selalu komut dengan Z
error selain itu Z stabilizer generator juga komut dengan Z gate apa pun yang mungkin kita pilih untuk diterapkan sebagai
koreksi untuk Z error demikian pula X stabilizer generator mendeteksi Z error tapi mereka sama sekali
tidak menyadari X error dan koreksi jadi kita bisa pada dasarnya memikirkan Z stabilizer generator sebagai mewakili
kode linear klasik yang melindungi terhadap bit flip atau dengan kata lain X error sementara X stabilizer generator
mewakili kode linear klasik dalam basis plus-minus yang sepenuhnya secara independen melindungi terhadap flip
antara keadaan plus dan minus atau dengan kata lain error phase flip atau Z error jadi sekarang sudah cukup jelas apa yang terjadi
dengan kode Steane itu hanyalah kode Hamming 7-4-3 untuk error bit flip dan kode Hamming 7-4-3 untuk error phase
flip sekali lagi fakta bahwa Z stabilizer generator dan X stabilizer generator komut sangat diperlukan
itu tidak akan menjadi kode stabilizer yang valid jika tidak dan kamu bisa mengatakan bahwa ini adalah keberuntungan bahwa kode Hamming 7-4-3
berjalan seperti ini tapi ada banyak pilihan lain yang bisa dibuat untuk pasangan kode linear klasik yang akan memberi kita kode stabilizer yang valid
ketika digabungkan dengan cara ini sekarang kembali ke kode CSS secara umum misalkan Z stabilizer
generator memungkinkan koreksi hingga katakanlah JX error dan X stabilizer generator memungkinkan koreksi
hingga k Z error jadi dalam kasus kode Steane J dan K keduanya adalah satu karena
kode Hamming 7-4-3 bisa mengoreksi satu bit flip tapi secara umum angka J dan K ini bisa berbeda
kemudian berdasarkan diskretisasi error kode CSS bisa mengoreksi error apa pun pada sejumlah qubit hingga
minimum dari J dan K itu karena ketika kita mengukur sindrom error sembarang pada sejumlah
qubit secara efektif runtuh secara probabilistik menjadi beberapa kombinasi X error Z error atau keduanya dan kemudian
X error dan Z error bisa dideteksi dan dikoreksi secara independen jadi selama kita punya dua
kode linear klasik yang cocok dalam artian bahwa mereka memberikan kita X dan Z stabilizer generator yang komut kode
CSS yang kita dapatkan dengan menggabungkannya pada dasarnya mewarisi properti koreksi error dari dua kode dalam artian yang baru saja saya
jelaskan perhatikan bahwa ada harga yang harus dibayar meskipun yaitu kita tidak bisa mengkodekan sebanyak qubit seperti yang bisa kita lakukan dengan bit
menggunakan dua kode klasik karena total jumlah generator stabilizer untuk kode CSS adalah jumlah dari
jumlah parity check untuk dua kode klasik dan setiap generator stabilizer memotong dimensi ruang kode
menjadi setengahnya misalnya kode Hamming 7-4-3 memungkinkan pengkodean empat bit klasik karena kita hanya memiliki
tiga parity check untuk kode ini sedangkan kode Steane 7 Cubit hanya mengkodekan satu qubit karena memiliki enam
generator stabilizer hal terakhir yang akan saya jelaskan tentang kode CSS secara umum dalam pelajaran ini menyangkut ruang kode dari kode CSS
dan seperti apa tampilannya dan ini juga akan memberi kita kesempatan untuk memeriksa secara sedikit lebih detail hubungan yang perlu berlaku antara
dua kode linear klasik agar mereka kompatibel dalam artian kita bisa menggabungkannya untuk membentuk kode CSS
pertimbangkan kode CSS sembarang pada N qubit dan biarkan Z1 sampai Zs menjadi string parity check n-bit
yang bersesuaian dengan Z stabilizer generator ini berarti bahwa kode linear
klasik yang dideskripsikan oleh Z stabilizer generator yang akan kita sebut CZ hanya untuk membantu kita mengingat bahwa ini
adalah kode yang bersesuaian dengan Z stabilizer generator mengambil bentuk yang ditampilkan di sini di layar dalam kata-kata kode mengandung setiap
string U yang hasil kali binernya dengan setiap string parity check adalah nol nah jika kita mau kita juga bisa
mempertimbangkan kode berbeda yang berasal dari string-string yang sama yang akan kita sebut DZ dan idenya di sini adalah kita memikirkan
string-string Z1 sampai Zs ini bukan sebagai string parity check tapi sebagai generator
pada titik ini tidak jelas mengapa kita ingin memikirkan kode ini tapi kita bisa dan ternyata relevan untuk
diskusi ini kode ini disebut kode dual dari CZ dan biasa dinotasikan CZ perp artinya CZ dengan simbol tegak lurus
sebagai superskrip tapi kita akan menyebutnya DZ dan itu akan cukup mudah diingat karena D adalah singkatan dari
dual kita juga bisa melakukan hal serupa dengan X stabilizer generator jadi kali ini CX adalah kode linear klasik
yang string parity check-nya bersesuaian dengan X stabilizer generator dan DX adalah kode dual dari kode ini sebagai catatan sampingan
kita sekarang bisa mendeskripsikan kondisi yang harus berlaku agar CZ dan CX kompatibel dalam artian kita bisa
memasangkannya sebagai kode CSS dalam artian kode-kode itu sendiri secara khusus harus dipenuhi bahwa
DZ terkandung dalam CX atau ekuivalennya bahwa DX terkandung dalam CZ dan sekarang
mungkin untuk mendeskripsikan ruang kode dari kode CSS yang berasal dari dua kode ini dan satu cara untuk mendeskripsikannya adalah bahwa
itu adalah ruang yang dicakup oleh semua vektor yang berbentuk seperti yang ditampilkan di layar dalam kata-kata mereka terlihat seperti superposisi seragam
atas string-string dalam kode dual DX dari kode yang bersesuaian dengan X stabilizer generator yang digeser
oleh atau diXOR dengan string-string dalam kode CZ yang bersesuaian dengan Z stabilizer generator dan kita akan melihat seperti apa ini
dalam kasus spesifik kode Steane sebentar lagi ini masuk akal karena keadaan dalam ruang kode harus merupakan
vektor eigen plus satu dari semua generator stabilizer dan khususnya mengalikan dengan salah satu dari X
stabilizer generator setara dengan mengXOR dengan string X yang bersesuaian jadi itulah mengapa superposisi seragam ini
atas DX yang digeser oleh string berbeda muncul seperti ini pilihan berbeda untuk shift
yang diwakili oleh string Y dalam ekspresi ini bisa memberikan vektor yang sama omong-omong jadi keadaan-keadaan ini tidak semuanya berbeda tapi bersama-sama mereka mencakup
seluruh ruang kode ada simetri di sini antara X dan Z stabilizer generator dan
kode yang bersesuaian dengan keduanya dan jadi kita bisa menggunakan simetri tersebut untuk mendeskripsikan vektor dalam ruang kode dengan cara analog dengan menukar x dan Z tapi
kita juga perlu menukar basis standar dengan basis plus-minus itulah mengapa operasi Hadamard muncul dalam
ekspresi ini sekarang untuk contoh yang sudah dijanjikan yaitu kode Steane kita mendapatkan dua ini sebagai kemungkinan
pengkodean dari keadaan basis standar nol dan satu khususnya kita bisa mengkodekan keadaan nol sebagai superposisi seragam
atas delapan string dalam kode dual dari kode Hamming 7-4-3 yang ternyata adalah setengah dari string dalam kode Hamming 7-4-3 dan kita
bisa mengkodekan keadaan satu dengan cara yang sama kecuali bahwa semua stringnya diXOR dengan string all-one dalam kasus ini
karena string tersebut ada dalam kode Hamming 7-4-3 tapi bukan dalam kode dualnya satu komentar terakhir di sini adalah bahwa kita sering
tidak terlalu peduli dengan seperti apa vektor dalam ruang kode kita karena secara umum kita tidak perlu mengetahui ini untuk menggunakan
kode-kodenya jadi jika penjelasan ini tidak jelas ini sebenarnya bukan sesuatu yang perlu dikhawatirkan terlalu banyak tapi ini tentu saja
wajar untuk ditanyakan seperti apa vektor dalam ruang kode dari kode CSS dan deskripsi ini memberikan jawaban untuk
pertanyaan itu selanjutnya kita akan membahas kode CSS spesifik yang dikenal sebagai kode Torus yang merupakan contoh dari sesuatu yang dikenal sebagai
kode koreksi error kuantum topologi kode ini ditemukan oleh Alexei Kitaev pada
tahun 1997 bahkan kode Torus bukanlah satu kode tapi justru merupakan keluarga kode satu untuk setiap bilangan bulat positif setidaknya
dua kode-kode ini memiliki beberapa Properti Kunci properti kunci pertama adalah
bahwa semua generator stabilizer memiliki bobot rendah sebagai operasi Pauli khususnya mereka semua akan memiliki
bobot empat dan ini bagus karena berarti bahwa setiap pengukuran generator stabilizer tidak perlu melibatkan
terlalu banyak qubit kadang orang berbicara tentang kode LDPC kuantum atau kode Quantum Low Density Parity
Check dan inilah yang dimaksud dengan istilah ini di mana dalam kasus ini low berarti empat jadi kode Torus adalah contoh dari
kode LDPC kuantum kode Torus juga memiliki apa yang disebut lokalitas geometris yang berarti bahwa tidak
hanya generator stabilizernya memiliki bobot rendah tapi juga memungkinkan untuk mengatur qubit secara spasial sehingga
setiap pengukuran generator stabilizer hanya melibatkan qubit yang berdekatan yang membuat pengukuran-pengukuran ini lebih mudah untuk diimplementasikan
secara prinsip dan akhirnya kode-kode ini memiliki jarak yang besar sehingga mereka bisa mentoleransi tingkat error yang relatif tinggi
berikut adalah cara kerja kode-kode ini pertama biarkan huruf kapital L menjadi bilangan bulat positif
yang setidaknya dua dan pertimbangkan kisi L kali L dengan batas yang disebut periodik
misalnya berikut adalah kisi L kali L untuk L sama dengan 8 dan perhatikan bahwa garis-garis
di sebelah kanan dan di bawah adalah garis putus-putus dan idenya di sini adalah bahwa kita ingin memikirkan garis putus-putus di sebelah kanan sebagai garis yang sama dengan
garis di sebelah kiri dan demikian pula garis putus-putus di bawah adalah garis yang sama dengan yang ada di
atas jadi jika kita benar-benar ingin merealisasikan konfigurasi semacam ini secara fisik kita akan membutuhkan tiga
dimensi khususnya kita bisa membentuk silinder dengan pertama mencocokkan sisi kiri dan kanan lalu membengkokkan
silinder tersebut sehingga lingkaran di ujungnya yang dulunya adalah tepi atas dan bawah dari kisi bertemu atau kamu
bisa mencocokkan bagian atas dan bawah terlebih dahulu lalu sisinya ini berfungsi kedua cara dan tidak masalah cara mana yang kamu lakukan demi
diskusi ini apa yang kita dapatkan adalah sebuah Torus atau dengan kata lain donat meskipun memikirkannya sebagai ban dalam kendaraan adalah
mungkin gambaran yang lebih baik untuk dimiliki karena ini bukanlah sesuatu yang lunak kisi tersebut sebenarnya hanya menjadi permukaan dari sebuah
Torus dan inilah asal nama kode Torus cara kamu bisa bergerak
di sekitar sebuah Torus seperti ini dengan asumsi bahwa kamu bisa bergerak antara titik-titik yang berdekatan di kisi kemungkinan besar akan familiar bagi orang-orang yang pernah memainkan game video old school
di mana jika kamu bergerak melewati tepi atas layar kamu muncul di bawah dan demikian pula untuk tepi kiri dan kanan layar
dan sebagian besar ini adalah cara saya mendeskripsikan kisi ini sebagai alternatif dari berbicara secara khusus tentang sebuah Torus
dalam ruang tiga dimensi selanjutnya kita membayangkan bahwa qubit ditempatkan
pada tepi-tepi kisi seperti yang diilustrasikan di sini di layar di mana qubit ditunjukkan dengan lingkaran biru solid
perhatikan omong-omong bahwa qubit yang ditempatkan pada garis putus-putus tidak solid dan itu karena kita sudah mewakili qubit tersebut
baik dengan yang ada di sepanjang bagian atas atau sisi kiri mengingat bahwa garis di bagian atas dan kiri adalah persis garis yang sama dengan yang
ditunjukkan oleh garis putus-putus di bagian bawah dan kanan dan jadi jika kita menghitung semua qubit ini kita mendapatkan 2 kali l kuadrat qubit dan satu
cara untuk melihat itu adalah mengamati bahwa kita mendapatkan l kuadrat qubit pada tepi horizontal dan L kuadrat qubit pada tepi vertikal
jadi itulah tata letak qubit kita dan untuk mendeskripsikan kode Torus itu sendiri kita hanya perlu mendeskripsikan generator
stabilizer dan ada dua jenisnya pertama kita punya Z stabilizer generator
dan ini bersesuaian dengan tile atau plaque dalam gambar dan kedua kita punya X stabilizer
generator dan ini bersesuaian dengan vertex dalam gambar jadi misalnya berikut adalah satu
generator stabilizer yang berarti bahwa kita me-tensor bersama satu operasi Pauli Z untuk setiap qubit yang menyentuh tile ini beserta matriks identitas
pada semua qubit lainnya dan itu memberi kita operasi Pauli berbobot empat dan berikut adalah contoh dari X
stabilizer generator di mana kita punya matriks Pauli X yang bekerja pada empat qubit yang berinsiden pada vertex ini beserta
matriks identitas pada semua qubit lainnya jadi sekali lagi ini adalah operasi Pauli berbobot empat penting bahwa untuk kedua
jenis generator stabilizer ini kita menyertakan yang melingkupi batas periodik dan berikut adalah contoh dari X stabilizer generator
yang melakukan ini sekarang agar mendapatkan kode stabilizer yang valid kita perlu generator stabilizer
untuk komut Z stabilizer generator semua komut satu sama lain karena Z komut dengan dirinya sendiri dan identitas
komut dengan segalanya dan demikian pula untuk X stabilizer generator juga jelas bahwa Z stabilizer generator dan X
stabilizer generator komut ketika mereka bekerja secara non-trivial pada himpunan qubit yang disjoint seperti untuk dua generator yang ditampilkan
di sini kemungkinan yang tersisa adalah bahwa Z stabilizer generator dan X stabilizer generator tumpang tindih dan
setiap kali itu terjadi selalu ada dua qubit yang mereka tumpang tindih jadi generator stabilizer komut karena ZZ
dan XX komut sekarang ini bukanlah himpunan generator stabilizer minimal khususnya jika kita mengalikan
semua Z stabilizer generator bersama kita mendapatkan identitas karena setiap Qubit dikalikan oleh Z dua kali
satu kali untuk setiap tile yang menyentuh Qubit itu berarti bahwa mengalikan semua Z stabilizer generator bersama
kecuali satu di antaranya memberi kita yang terakhir itu jadi mereka tidak independen tapi jika kita menghapus salah satu dari mereka kita akan mendapatkan
himpunan yang independen dan hal yang sama berlaku untuk X stabilizer generator jadi kita bisa menghapus satu dari masing-masing
dan tidak masalah yang mana yang kita hapus dan itu meninggalkan l kuadrat minus satu generator stabilizer dari setiap jenis untuk
jelasnya dan ini adalah sesuatu yang saya singgung dalam pelajaran sebelumnya kita sebenarnya memang peduli tentang semua generator stabilizer ini dan dalam arti
yang benar-benar operasional kita tidak benar-benar akan memilih satu dari setiap jenis untuk diabaikan tapi demi menganalisis kode kita bisa
membayangkan bahwa satu generator stabilizer dari setiap jenis telah dihapus sehingga kita mendapatkan himpunan pembangkit minimal dengan mengingat
bahwa kita selalu bisa menyimpulkan hasil dari generator yang dihapus ini dengan menganggap mereka sebagai observabel dari hasil semua generator stabilizer lainnya
dari jenis yang sama sehingga jumlah qubit yang dikodekan oleh kode ini sama dengan total jumlah
qubit yaitu 2 kali l kuadrat dikurangi total jumlah generator stabilizer dalam himpunan pembangkit minimal yaitu 2 kali l kuadrat minus
1 dan itu berarti kita bisa mengkodekan 2 qubit saya tidak berargumen omong-omong bahwa ruang kode ini non-trivial tapi memang
demikian dan saya biarkan kamu untuk meyakinkan dirimu sendiri bahwa tidak ada cara untuk mengalikan generator stabilizer bersama dengan cara yang memberi kita
minus 1 kali identitas jadi itulah kode Torus itu sendiri dan pada titik ini mungkin tidak
jelas sama sekali mengapa kode ini seharusnya bagus untuk koreksi error kuantum masih ada yang perlu kita analisis dan apa yang akan kita temukan adalah bahwa ini
sebenarnya adalah kode koreksi error kuantum yang cukup menakjubkan untuk memahami bagaimana kode Torus berfungsi sebagai kode koreksi error kuantum
kita akan mulai dengan mempertimbangkan berbagai error dan sindrom yang mereka hasilkan hal pertama yang perlu diperhatikan adalah bahwa
kode Torus adalah kode CSS karena semua generator stabilizer kita adalah Z atau X stabilizer
generator dan itu berarti bahwa X error dan Z error bisa dideteksi dan kemungkinan dikoreksi
secara terpisah dan sebenarnya ada simetri sederhana antara Z dan X stabilizer generator yang memungkinkan kita untuk menganalisis X
error dan Z error pada dasarnya dengan cara yang sama jadi saya akan fokus pada X error yang kemungkinan dideteksi oleh Z
stabilizer generator dan kamu bisa menterjemahkan segalanya ke Z error yang kemungkinan dideteksi oleh X stabilizer generator menggunakan persis
ide yang sama berikut adalah gambar yang mengilustrasikan qubit persegi dua kita pada tepi kisi L
kali dengan batas periodik dan kita bisa membayangkan bahwa ini diletakkan di permukaan sebuah
Torus saat ini semua qubit berwarna biru menunjukkan bahwa ini adalah qubit yang belum terpengaruh oleh
error jadi kamu harus membayangkan bahwa pada titik ini keadaan qubit ini berada dalam ruang kode untuk
kode ini seperti yang saya sebutkan fokus kita adalah pada X error dan sebentar lagi kita akan menggunakan lingkaran magenta untuk menunjukkan qubit yang
telah terpengaruh oleh X error X error dideteksi oleh Z stabilizer generator yang bersesuaian
dengan tile dalam gambar jadi yang bisa kita lakukan adalah membiarkan Tile Putih menunjukkan hasil pengukuran plus satu atau dengan kata lain entri dalam sindrom yang bersesuaian dengan generator tersebut sementara tile abu-abu akan menunjukkan hasil pengukuran minus satu
kamu bisa memikirkan hasil plus satu atau dengan kata lain tile putih sebagai menunjukkan bahwa generator stabilizer yang bersesuaian
bahagia semuanya tampak baik-baik saja untuk generator ini sementara hasil minus satu atau tile abu-abu
menunjukkan bahwa generator stabilizer yang bersesuaian tidak bahagia karena jelas sebuah error pasti terjadi untuk menyebabkan ini
jadi saat ini semua generator stabilizer kita bahagia karena tidak ada error yang terjadi sekarang jika kita memikirkan
sebuah Z stabilizer generator semua yang ia lakukan adalah mengukur paritas dari 4 qubit yang menyentuh tile dengan
menggunakan basis standar jadi hasil plus satu tidak menunjukkan bahwa tidak ada X error yang terjadi pada keempat qubit ini
melainkan itu menunjukkan bahwa jumlah X error yang genap telah terjadi sedangkan hasil minus satu menunjukkan
bahwa jumlah X error yang ganjil telah terjadi jadi sekarang mari kita perkenalkan sebuah X error dan lihat apa yang
terjadi dua Z stabilizer generator yang bersesuaian dengan tile yang menyentuh Qubit ini sekarang tidak bahagia karena
X error ini anti-komut dengan kedua generator ini atau ekuivalennya dalam artian basis standar kita sekarang berada dalam
keadaan di mana kedua himpunan empat qubit yang bersesuaian dengan dua tile memiliki paritas ganjil jadi itulah efek dari satu
X error jadi jika kita mengukur sindrom ini dan kita tahu atau mengasumsikan bahwa hanya satu X error yang terjadi kita bisa dengan mudah
menyimpulkan qubit mana yang terbalik dan kita bisa cukup membaliknya kembali dengan X gate sekarang mari kita lihat apa yang terjadi
saat kita memperkenalkan X error tambahan dan khususnya mari kita lihat apa yang terjadi saat X error kedua terjadi pada
qubit lain yang menyentuh salah satu tile abu-abu katakanlah tile abu-abu di atas seperti
ini tile itu sekarang bahagia karena dua X error telah terjadi pada qubit yang menyentuh tile ini dan dua adalah genap jadi
dua X error ini bersama-sama komut dengan generator stabilizer untuk tile ini cara lain untuk mengatakan ini adalah bahwa
X error kedua ini telah menggeser semua keadaan basis standar untuk keempat qubit ini dari paritas ganjil kembali ke paritas genap
tile di sebelah kiri dari X error baru ini di sisi lain sekarang tidak bahagia
kita bisa melanjutkan proses ini dengan menambahkan X error baru dan selama kita membentuk rantai X error yang berdekatan di mana berdekatan berarti qubit menyentuh
tile yang sama kita akan secara efektif mendorong hasil pengukuran minus1 ini ke sekitar dan apa yang kita temukan adalah bahwa kita selalu punya
hasil pengukuran sindrom minus satu di titik akhir dari rantai error yang berdekatan jadi kita selalu bisa mendeteksi rantai
X error yang berdekatan selama mereka memiliki titik akhir bisa jadi ada beberapa rantai tapi kita akan kembali ke
kemungkinan ini nanti namun mungkin saja kita bisa punya rantai X error yang berdekatan yang
tidak memiliki titik akhir yang artinya rantai Error kita bisa membentuk loop tertutup jadi mari kita tambahkan lebih banyak error sehingga
mereka membentuk loop tertutup seperti ini misalnya kita sekarang punya jumlah X error yang genap
pada setiap tile jadi setiap generator stabilizer sekarang bahagia dan apa yang kita temukan adalah bahwa loop tertutup
dari X error yang berdekatan tidak terdeteksi oleh kode ini karena kita mendapatkan sindrom all-plus1 dalam
kasus seperti itu jadi itu mungkin terasa agak mengecewakan bahkan kita hanya butuh empat X error yang berdekatan untuk membentuk loop tertutup
dan kita berharap sesuatu yang lebih baik dari kode berjarak 4 namun beberapa loop tertutup dari
X error yang berdekatan sendiri ada dalam stabilizer ingat bahwa kita punya X stabilizer generator untuk setiap vertex dalam
kisi dan jika kita mengalikan generator X stabilizer yang berdekatan bersama kita bisa membentuk loop tertutup dari operasi X
seperti yang kita miliki di sini untuk loop tertutup yang kita konstruksi beberapa saat yang lalu jadi beberapa loop tertutup dari X error
seperti yang ditampilkan di sini sebenarnya sama sekali bukan error karena mereka ada dalam stabilizer sehingga mereka tidak melakukan apa pun sama sekali pada ruang kode ada namun
beberapa loop tertutup dari X error yang tidak ada dalam stabilizer dan oleh karena itu mereka mewakili error non-trivial yang tidak terdeteksi
oleh kode dan ada cara yang cukup sederhana untuk mengkarakterisasi berbagai jenis
loop loop yang melintasi setiap garis dalam kisi yang berarti setiap garis vertikal dari atas ke bawah dan setiap garis horizontal
dari kiri ke kanan sejumlah genap kali selalu merupakan produk dari X stabilizer generator termasuk contoh
yang ditampilkan di layar maupun loop yang mungkin jauh lebih rumit termasuk kemungkinan bahwa mereka melintasi batas periodik tapi
meskipun demikian dengan mengalikan loop tertutup X error ini dengan X stabilizer generator mereka bisa secara efektif diperkecil menjadi
tidak ada dan itu memang benar omong-omong bahwa kita hanya bisa mendapatkan loop seperti ini dengan mengalikan generator X stabilizer bersama karena setiap X stabilizer
generator menempatkan jumlah operasi X yang genap pada setiap garis horizontal dan pada setiap garis vertikal
jenis loop tertutup lainnya yang bisa kita miliki adalah yang melintasi setidaknya satu garis sejumlah ganjil kali seperti
yang ditampilkan di sini yang melintasi setiap garis horizontal tepat sekali dan berikut adalah contoh lain yang melintasi
setiap garis vertikal tepat sekali jadi ini adalah contoh error non-trivial yang tidak terdeteksi oleh kode tapi kunci
di sini adalah bahwa satu-satunya cara untuk membentuk loop tertutup seperti ini adalah dengan mengelilingi Torus baik di sekitar lubang di tengah
Torus atau melalui lubang atau bisa keduanya ini adalah properti topologi
yang menyangkut Torus ini pada dasarnya tentang lubang dan itulah mengapa ini disebut kode koreksi error kuantum topologi
dalam artian visualisasi kisi dua dimensi dengan batas periodik ini sebuah rantai dalam kategori ini harus
melingkupi satu atau kedua batas periodik dengan cara yang membuat tidak mungkin untuk mengontraksi loop tersebut menjadi
sebuah titik dengan mengalikannya dengan X stabilizer generator rantai seperti itu mungkin lebih
rumit dari yang diilustrasikan di sini tapi ini adalah yang terpendek yang mungkin dimiliki loop seperti itu karena ia harus entah bagaimana mengelilingi
satu atau kedua batas periodik dan apa yang ini implikasikan adalah bahwa bobot minimum dari error non-trivial
yang tidak terdeteksi adalah L setiap loop tertutup dengan lebih sedikit error dari itu harus masuk ke kategori pertama dan oleh karena itu
ada dalam stabilizer dan rantai error yang tidak membentuk loop tertutup terdeteksi oleh kode dan itu saja itulah mengapa kode ini
berfungsi dan apa yang kita dapatkan adalah kode stabilizer 2 l kuadrat 2 L kita menggunakan 2 L kuadrat
qubit untuk mengkodekan 2 qubit dan kode memiliki jarak L selanjutnya saya akan sedikit membahas tentang
mengoreksi error dengan kode Torus meskipun saya tidak akan terlalu jauh ke dalam detail jika kita mengukur sindrom dan
kita melihat sesuatu selain sindrom all-plus1 di mana saya berbicara di sini hanya tentang Z stabilizer generator
maka hasil minus satu menunjukkan kepada kita titik akhir dari satu atau lebih rantai X error yang berdekatan dan kita bisa mencoba untuk mengoreksi
error ini dengan memasangkan hasil minus satu bersama dan membentuk rantai koreksi X di antara mereka dan saat
melakukan ini masuk akal untuk memilih jalur terpendek untuk koreksi kita misalnya jika kita mengukur
sindrom seperti yang ditampilkan di sini maka kita bisa memilih jalur ini di antara tile yang tidak bahagia dan menerapkan X
gate sebagai koreksi sepanjang jalur ini tentu saja rantai error sebenarnya yang menyebabkan sindrom tersebut bisa
berbeda seperti yang ditampilkan di sini tapi tidak apa-apa selama error dan koreksi bersama-sama
masuk ke dalam stabilizer juga mungkin bahwa koreksi kita melengkapi sebuah loop mengelilingi
Torus yang buruk karena dalam melakukan ini kita telah menyebabkan error logis jadi strategi koreksi
sepanjang jalur terpendek ini mengoreksi error berbobot rendah tapi mungkin tidak berfungsi untuk error berbobot lebih tinggi tapi tentu saja kita tidak bisa
mengharapkan lebih dari kode koreksi error kuantum mana pun lebih mungkin mungkin tergantung pada model noise adalah bahwa
kita mengamati banyak minus satu dalam sindrom dan dalam kasus ini kita bisa menggunakan algoritma klasik yang efisien untuk membantu
kita memasangkannya dan menemukan error berbobot terendah yang mewakili sindrom seperti yang saya sebutkan dalam pelajaran sebelumnya
ini mungkin tidak selalu mengoreksi penjelasan yang paling mungkin untuk sindrom tapi memang berfungsi cukup baik secara umum
dan selalu berhasil mengoreksi error yang memiliki bobot secara ketat kurang dari setengah jarak L dan saya juga harus
menyebutkan bahwa ada strategi lain yang lebih cocok untuk model error yang berbeda sudah lebih dari 25 tahun sejak
kode Torus ditemukan dan dalam waktu itu ada banyak pekerjaan pada kode koreksi error kuantum termasuk
kode koreksi error kuantum topologi lainnya yang terinspirasi oleh kode Torus maupun kode yang didasarkan pada ide yang berbeda
saya tentu tidak bisa memberikan daftar lengkap dari semua konstruksi kode yang berbeda yang diketahui tapi saya akan sedikit menggaruk permukaan
dan secara singkat menyebutkan beberapa contoh yang terkenal pertama ternyata tidak
benar-benar penting bahwa kode Torus memiliki batas periodik yaitu mungkin untuk memotong hanya sebagian dari kode Torus dan
meletakkannya datar di permukaan dua dimensi daripada di sebuah Torus dan apa yang kita dapatkan dengan melakukan itu disebut surface
code misalnya jika kita memotong tepi kisi dengan pola yang ditampilkan di sini dengan apa yang disebut tepi kasar di atas
dan bawah dan tepi halus di samping dan sesuai dengan itu kita menyertakan kasus tepi untuk generator stabilizer
maka kita mendapatkan kode yang bisa mengkodekan hanya satu Qubit kali ini tapi kode tersebut meskipun demikian mewarisi karakteristik paling
penting dari kode Torus khususnya error non-trivial yang tidak terdeteksi untuk kode ini harus
bersesuaian dengan rantai error yang membentang dari tepi kiri ke tepi kanan atau dari atas ke bawah
tergantung apakah itu rantai X error atau Z error masing-masing juga mungkin untuk memotong
tepi secara diagonal untuk mendapatkan apa yang kadang disebut surface code yang dirotasi dan melakukan itu bisa membantu membuat
kode lebih ekonomis dalam hal berapa banyak qubit yang digunakan misalnya jika kita mengambil surface code ini
dan kita membuang beberapa qubit meninggalkan persegi yang berorientasi secara diagonal kita mendapatkan surface code lain
selama kita menentukan generator stabilizer di batas dengan cara yang benar diagram seperti ini
membantu untuk menjelaskan bagaimana generator stabilizer didefinisikan di mana tile hitam termasuk yang bulat di tepi menunjukkan X stabilizer
generator dan yang putih menunjukkan Z stabilizer generator yang ada di batas omong-omong hanyalah 2 Qubit XX
atau ZZ stabilizer generator kali ini dan kamu akan umum melihat diagram-diagram ini dirotasi sebesar
45 derajat kelas lain yang menarik dari kode yang juga masuk ke dalam kategori umum kode topologi adalah kode
warna saya tidak akan menjelaskan secara tepat bagaimana cara kerjanya tapi satu cara untuk memikirkannya adalah bahwa mereka adalah generalisasi geometris
dari kode Steane 7 Cubit jadi mari kita pertimbangkan kode Steane tujuh qubit dan misalkan kita menomori
qubit kita menggunakan konvensi pemesanan ket seperti yang ditampilkan di sini di layar kita kemudian bisa mengasosiasikan tujuh
qubit ini dengan vertex dari grafik yang ditampilkan di sini dan apa yang kita temukan adalah bahwa generator stabilizer cocok
dengan tile atau face yang dibentuk oleh tepi grafik dan untuk setiap tile kita selalu punya Z stabilizer
generator dan X stabilizer generator yang bekerja secara non-trivial tepat pada qubit yang ditemukan di vertex dari
tile itu ini bagus karena seperti halnya kode Torus kita punya lokalitas geometris untuk kode ini jadi kita tidak perlu
memindahkan qubit jarak jauh untuk mengukur generator stabilizer dan fakta bahwa Z dan X stabilizer generator selalu bekerja secara non-trivial pada
himpunan qubit yang persis sama juga bagus karena alasan yang terhubung dengan komputasi kuantum fault-tolerant yang akan saya
jelaskan lebih lanjut dalam pelajaran berikutnya kode warna adalah kode koreksi error kuantum yang menggeneralisasi
pola dasar ini di mana kita pada dasarnya melakukan hal yang sama kecuali dengan grafik yang berbeda misalnya berikut adalah grafik dengan
19 vertex yang berfungsi ini memberi kita kode yang mengkodekan 1 Cubit ke dalam 19 dan kebetulan memiliki
jarak lima ini disebut kode warna omong-omong karena salah satu kondisi yang diperlukan pada grafik adalah bahwa face-face dapat diwarnai tiga warna yang berarti
bahwa kita bisa mewarnai face-face dengan tiga warna dan kita tidak pernah memiliki dua face dengan warna yang sama yang berbagi sebuah tepi
warna-warna sebenarnya tidak penting untuk kode itu sendiri kita hanya punya x dan z stabilizer generator untuk setiap face tanpa memandang warnanya tapi warna-warna
tersebut ternyata penting untuk menganalisis cara kerjanya jadi itu adalah dua keluarga kode yang sangat terkenal
tapi ada banyak konstruksi lain yang diketahui termasuk yang didasarkan pada ide yang mirip dengan keluarga kode ini maupun
yang sepenuhnya berbeda contoh spesifik dari kode koreksi error kuantum yang baru-baru ini
ditemukan oleh beberapa rekan saya di IBM dikenal sebagai kode gross yang dinamai demikian karena gross adalah selusin
lusin atau 144 khususnya kode ini mengkodekan 12 qubit ke dalam 144 qubit dan memiliki
jarak 12 saya tidak akan menjelaskan bagaimana kode ini berfungsi secara detail ini mirip dengan kode Torus kecuali bahwa setiap
generator stabilizer sekarang melibatkan dua qubit tambahan yang hanya sedikit lebih jauh ini tidak memiliki embedding planar
seperti surface code tapi memiliki apa yang disebut biplanar embedding yang berarti bahwa dua lapisan qubit diperlukan daripada
satu ini masuk ke dalam keluarga kode yang disebut bivariate bicycle code dan yang sangat luar biasa tentangnya adalah
bahwa mereka jauh lebih efisien daripada kode Torus atau surface code dalam artian bahwa jauh lebih banyak qubit bisa dikodekan sementara secara bersamaan mereka
mentoleransi tingkat error yang kira-kira sama untuk kode gross 144 qubit tambahan diperlukan untuk pengukuran sindrom
sehingga total jumlah qubit yang diperlukan adalah 288 yang menjadikannya kandidat yang sangat menjanjikan untuk teknologi hari ini
dan itulah yang menyimpulkan pelajaran ini yang membahas tentang konstruksi kode koreksi error kuantum termasuk kode CSS kode Torus dan
sekilas tentang konstruksi kode kuantum lainnya termasuk surface code dan kode warna saya harap kamu akan bergabung dengan saya untuk
pelajaran berikutnya dan terakhir dari seri ini tentang komputasi kuantum fault-tolerant yang membahas tantangan melakukan
komputasi pada keadaan kuantum yang terkodekan menggunakan operasi dan komponen komputasi yang rentan terhadap
error sampai jumpa lagi